[music]
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of [music] your
primary care physician. Statements in
this program have not been evaluated by
the FDA. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. who are
honored to continue and share the
teachings of the founding
>> [music]
>> Hello everybody. Go ahead and let people
into our live Zoom. So if you are
watching us on any of our live streams
and or even watching a replay and you
would like to draw join us live, please
go to dailyw withdocoom.com.
That is Monday through Friday from 12 to
12:50 p.m. Pacific time, 1:00 Mountain
time, 2 o'clock central time, and 3:00
Eastern time for those of you who are
here. We are worldwide, even down in
South Africa where we are broadcasting
throughout all of our platforms. And
folks, we are on so many different
platforms, I don't even have them
memorized yet, which I think is
absolutely fantastic because the
information that you're going to be
hearing today is not geographically
relevant. It's worldwide relevant.
Folks, my name is Becca Dukes. As the
hostess of this program, Daily with Doc,
I am honored to be able to bring to you
empowering information that allows you
as an individual to make and fine-tune
different things going on in your life
to
put you on a path, on a journey to
better health, optimal health. Wherever
it is that you're at, as long as you're
sucking air, you can do things to help
So, um, for comes I don't know how long
I was muted. How long was I muted for,
guys?
>> 30 seconds.
>> 30 seconds. Ah. All right. So, folks,
you are empowered. You are an empowered
individual. And those fine little tweaks
and tune tuning that you're going to
hear on today's program that are not
hard, they're not hard at all will lead
you on a path to better health to find
better or even optimal wellness when it
comes to your health or your family's
health or your community's health. We're
working on the world. So share this
program with others. You can find us on
YouTube and Facebook and Patreon and
Spotify and
um oh there's so many. I've got to
memorize them. I promise I will. I will.
But again, my name is Becca Dukes and if
I do have to let you know it is a FDA
requirement that I let you know that
this program is for educational purposes
only on the importance of nutritional
supplementation.
This program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician and
we do recommend that you work with your
doctors when starting a quality
supplementation program because folks
it is proven science that we are
continually making cells. So when you're
continually making something and the
stuff going into making it
is better and improving cells and cell
function, then what do you think has to
do with the chemicals that are
controlling or managing a poor health
situation?
They're going to be absorbed more. So,
we really encourage that you work with
your primary care physician because as
your body is gaining wellness and better
becoming better neutrified, it will need
less of that chemical that is being used
to man about managing folks. We're all
about giving the body what it needs to
do what it was designed to do and that's
not just barely survive that is thrive.
So, if you were invited by somebody
specific to watch this program, make
sure that you get back with them. Tell
them thank you. We are a resource to an
amazing community of coaches, health
coaches, certified holistic health
coaches. Many of them graduates of the
Institute of Holistic Health through
their certified holistic health coach
course. You can find more information
about that course at coach withdoc.
That's doc coachwithdoc.com.
Now,
if you are new and have never spoken to
anybody about Dr. Wallik, any of the
products that have he represents or the
company that he founded,
we invite you to get a hold of one of my
team. You can go to dailywithdoc.com
doc.com
and there is a contact us function
there. You can also call our 800 number
855-9493377.
Again 855-9493377.
Now we are we are health coaches. We are
not medically trained. We have not gone
through eight years of college plus
residency, all that stuff. We are
trained on the importance of nutrition.
So, if you've got a pharmaceutical
question, you need to get with your
doctor. You need to get with your
pharmacist and ask those questions. When
it comes to nutrition and based on what
Dr. Wallik would recommend for you,
based on the symptoms and the the the
disintegration that's going on within
the body, you're in the right place. So
without further ado, I would like to
bring on with me the one, the only
Dr. Joel Wallik. So Dr. Wallik, he
studied plants and soils and everything
going on there. He became a doctor of
veterary medicine where he has through
that study to become a doctor of
veterary medicine. He found a the cause
of a mass die off of pollution that
affects the thyroid. And folks, if
you're having thyroid issues and you're
eating processed meats, yeah, he has
already figured that out. So, listen up.
I know it's ep. It's like an epidemic
right now, Dr. Wallik, with thyroid is
issues, hypo hyper.
It's just crazy.
And then he, if that wasn't enough, he
also found the first nonhuman case of
cystic fibrosis, which was said to be a
human genetic condition. folks. He found
the cause of it. And he was also able to
reverse the condition
in a whole colony of monkeys.
And um yeah, that's not what they wanted
to hear. So they fired him. He went back
to school to become
a naturopathic physician where he is
using all of his education including
over 30,000 autopsies
through his postdo and pathology three
of them to help us as humans and our fur
babies feather bed babies gil babies.
Okay so Dr. Wallik welcome to Daily with
Doc. What great information do you have
to share with us today?
>> Well, [clears throat]
you you said a great story there. you
shared a great story and of course um
the
um results of the NIH grant $21 million
was at the Washington University in Sy's
there and um the text my thesis is in
the Smithsonian Institute is a national
treasure because I showed I proved there
were no genly transmitted diseases okay
all diseases said to be trans
transmitted genetically or autoimmune by
attacking yourself. No, we're all just
simple nutritional deficiencies.
And so was very very proud of that. And
um we had to sue the FDA in federal
court eight times, my great attorney
Jonathan Neort and I, to be able to put
these nutrients into baby formulas,
infamous, similac and the like. And we
were able to get rid of cystic fibrosis.
We're able to get rid of muscular feet.
They fired Jerry Lewis. The cystic
fibrosis foundation fired Jerry Lewis
similarly put a gag order on him so he
couldn't tell people he had found the
cure and the next day they shut down his
teleathon. This and even though he had
raised $2.6 6 billion dollars for them
over 46 years in the teleathon. This was
September 4th, 2011. They fired him in
2000, let's see here, two September 5th,
2011, they shut down a teleathon.
Terrible, terrible story. And then of
course
um the whole idea um that um these
diseases are genetic is out the window
now.
Today I want to talk about the
um let's see here. Let's talk about
something really big. Let's talk about
the metabolic syndrome.
Okay, metabolic syndrome makes up 25% of
the American population. Uh extreme
abdominal obesity, type two diabetes,
high blood pressure,
um
these kinds of things. And um it's it's
one of those things where it costs a
great deal of money. Uh it costs per
person, okay, with just um obesity,
okay, just the obesity part of it cost
$40,873
per per year per person. Okay?
And um 25% of are obese. And then you
throw them into the metabolic syndrome.
Okay? And then of course you also have
high blood pressure in the metabolic
syndrome.
Okay, we spend $131 billion a year just
treating the high blood pressure. And
then you also have type two diabetes
with the metabolic syndrome. Okay, we're
looking at $342 billion a year just to
treat the diabetes part.
And it's very very scary stuff. Okay. Uh
how much we're spending for a simple
nutritional deficient disease. I mean,
we're America. Nobody should be
nutritionally deficient. You have access
to all these wonderful products that
actually prevent it and reverse it.
Nobody should be suffering. Nobody
should be suffering from metabolic
syndrome. Nobody should be suffering
from diabetes. Nobody should be
suffering from high blood pressure.
Nobody should be suffering from obesity.
These are all simple nutritional
deficiency diseases. So, we have, you
know, we have a program for this. course
of thyroid issues uh that um scientific
study I did. I was involved with a mass
die off. 500
um lambs died in one night. They were
perfectly normal one day, the next
morning they were all dead. And the
farmer bought me 50
50 of these dead lambs and they all had
goer. They all had their blood was
black, not dark red, but black. And I I
asked the farmer, I said, "Gosh, what
about the rest of the lambs?" He said,
"They're all dead. All 500 were dead
this morning." "Oh my gosh, did they
show any sickness the day before?" "No,
they were perfectly normal the day
before." "Okay. Um do you live is your
farm around other farms?" "Oh, I'm
surrounded by farms." Okay. What kind of
animals? None. It's all just raising
grain and uh oh, what kind of fertilizer
they use? Well, they always use nitrate
fertilizers. I need a couple of five
gallon buckets full of the water from
the the the um pond that they're
drinking from. So he calls his people
and then within two hours I had that and
we did the testing. Sure enough there
was enough um nitrates in that drinking
water to kill a herd of elephants. Okay.
And what happened was for six months,
this was December [clears throat]
1963.
December 1963, just before Christmas.
Um, these lambs are perfectly healthy.
And in mid Missouri, the temperatures
run in December in their 30s, 40s, 50s,
40s, 50s, 30, 40s, 50s. Not too unusual.
And that's what was happening. But the
night they all died, the temperature
dropped to 16 and they all died of
hypothermia because their thyroids are
all dead. That was my first scientific
publication.
[clears throat] and Marlon Perkins, the
old new Jo Kingdom show, used that study
to get the $21 million grant from NIH,
which went to um the Washington
University in St. Louis, and I was a
pathologist on the project. 10 years
over 20,000 autopsies. My thesis is in
the Smithsonian Institute of National
Treasure. I'm very, very proud of that.
the book form of my thesis sells for
$25,000 each or sometimes $35,000 each
depending on what country you're in. Um
but we [clears throat] do of that okay
thesis is called epigenetics and one of
the founders co-founders of the science
of epigenetics
and that is essentially a thumbnail
sketch what was in that book we sell for
25 to $35,000
on the 20,000 autopsies showing that
there are no genot diseases. So,
epigenetics
um is what most people are going to buy
because you just have to pay $25, not
$25,000. P spend $25, get the same
information. Everybody needs that book.
Okay? That's the beginning of
epigenetics, the death, the death of the
false science. Okay? And of course, the
false science was of course that
everything was caused by genetics. And
that is not true. There are no generally
transmitted diseases. So with all that
said, uh we have programs to within
weeks, I tell people, give me 90 days,
but usually within weeks, I don't care
how long you've had your type two
diabetes, it's gone. I don't care how
long you've been obese. And being obese
is due to um and the metabolic syndrome
is due to nutritional deficiencies
particularly, you develop a behavior
called PAH, P I C A PAH, and you just
eat and eat and eat. And Frank, this is
your 13th meal today. Well, I'm still
hungry. Well, that's because they're
nutritionally deficient, particularly of
minerals. They're deficient in minerals.
They develop this behavior called PA.
And they eat and they eat and they eat.
You get them on one healthy
our um keto shake. It's a meal replacer.
It's not they add to a meal. Okay. Comes
in chocolate and strawberry. And um one
meal a day. Doesn't have to be the same
meal every day. and take the 90
essential nutrients to one healthy brain
and heart pack per 100 pounds of body
weight. You weigh 135 150 pounds. You
throw in one healthy brain and heart
pack, get about 150 pounds. You want to
start taking two health brain hard
packs. Two bottles of MSM and take three
at breakfast at dinner time. Um
doesn't hurt to throw in, let's see
here, the rebounder sports drink. Uh
don't forget evening drink. Don't forget
that keto shake. It's remember it's a
meal replacer. It's not to be added to a
meal. And we have the sweeties for the
diabetes. Three of those twice a day.
Don't cold turkey off your medication,
but as your blood sugar begins to drop,
you can slowly reduce it. Usually within
a couple of weeks, you won't be a
diabetic anymore. And the same thing
with high blood pressure. These are
ultimate daily classic tablets. Go ahead
and take three of those twice a day.
It's two bottles a month. and high blood
pressure where we spend $131 billion a
year, okay, just to treat the symptoms.
Don't call turkey off the medication,
but as the blood pressure begins to
drop, you can slowly reduce the
medication based on the numbers.
Obesity, we spend $260 billion for that
alone. Okay? And the medical system is
making trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars a year just
treating simple nutritional deficit
diseases. So, I urge you do your part.
Get away from the bad stuff. maximizes
it meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat,
brown, and oats, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. Even the diet drinks got to go
in carbonated water because they
neutralize stomach acids. So, you cannot
absorbut
minerals and digest food. The good Lord
gave us the ability to make stomach acid
so we could absorb minerals and digest
food. Don't try and neutralize or
eliminate stomach acid as part of your
healthy lifestyle and you'll add 25 to
50 healthy years to your life when you
get all that in balance. People say,
"Well, you know, I tried all this all
these nutrients. It didn't work." Well,
did you get off the gluten? Well, no. I
mean, you know, I have spaghetti for
lunch. I have pancakes for breakfast and
and bread for dinner. And well, there
you go. That's because you're not
absorbing the nutrients. If you're not
absorbing them, they're all coming out.
And the only
individuals making any benefit out of
all the nutrients you're taking are the
viruses, bacteria, and fungus in in the
um
the um
>> in the body.
>> The say again.
>> Okay.
So, they're definitely not benefiting
the body either, Dr. Wallick. And
>> no,
>> using the nutrition, I've tried all
those other ones and no, they didn't
work. But using your synergistic
formulas, I was able to
lose 100 pounds.
>> Wow.
>> And I did keto and used the keto shake
and yes, good foods, bad foods. I
focused on the good foods, Dr. Wallick,
and the good foods that were not high in
carbohydrates.
So, I left the bad foods alone, focused
on those that are on the good food side
that are low in carbohydrates, and
that's how I lost my 100 pounds.
>> Yeah. And that good good food, bad food
list is in the book, Dr. Wik's cooking
without the bad foods. Dr. W's cooking
out the bad foods. And um um every every
family needs to have that. There's 300
pages of safe cooking recipes list the
good foods, bad foods very clearly. And
um
septic tank is the word I was looking
for. Okay.
>> Most people are on a sewer septic tank
when they they it's kind of like a sewer
on a farm. They get the benefit of all
the nutrients coming through. Okay. And
so um we got to watch it. We got to do
everything right and you'll get the
benefits of all these nutrients. I have
so many famous people. Of course, we
have this this um uh chart coming out
here, this flip chart. Okay, it's coming
out soon. Or did we get the last two
bids? So, we know what we're doing here.
>> I did get one and I had the the last one
ask me one more question that I
responded to. So,
>> quick
72 pages and it has a lot of the famous
people, athletes.
>> Yeah. So, you're not muffled.
>> Okay. Athletes. Okay. We're talking
about singers. uh actors and actresses.
We're talking about people who were in
the government. We're talking about
pastors and rabbis. I I have pictures of
me with as we dealt with they and their
famil family's problems just with just
nutrition and all the medical doctors,
all the top medical doctors in the world
couldn't help them and just nutrition
solved their problems. So there you go.
>> There you go folks. You know,
epigenetics Dr. Welik was talking about
and he didn't see but I was holding that
up while he was talking about it. This
is my favorite book.
Ne, no, my second favorite book. Next to
the Bible, this book gave me the most
hope because I was told that I had
genetic conditions that I would just
have to live with and manage the rest of
my life. And I wasn't okay with that
because that management, most of it I
couldn't do because of being allergic to
the pain meds that they were wanting to
put me on. And now I don't need any of
them.
And it's all because I heard about Dr.
Wallik. I followed his program. I took I
drank the Kool-Aid, folks. Okay? And it
doesn't taste bad. And it really does
work. So, Dr. Wick, I contribute where I
am today physically, mentally to you.
So, I appreciate you so much and all of
the work that you have done, the books
that you have written, everything that's
gotten gone into making this information
available that it is my honor and
privilege to be able to bring that to
new levels through this program, Daily
with Doc. Well, we can't thank you
enough because you could have just
gotten better and walked away, but you
have spent a a good portion of your
adult life in getting this information
out to other people and helping them get
the same good results that you got. And
I cannot thank you enough. You're an
angel of God. Thank you for all the good
things you do.
>> Well, at least the last three plus
years, Dr. Wallik.
So, because I didn't find you until
about seven and a half coming up on
eight years ago. seven and a half years
ago. So yeah, amazing folks what the
body can do when you give it the right
stuff. As I mentioned, our products are
not not um heal or cure anything,
but the body has that innate ability to
use the right
nutrition and put it to work within to
manufacture what the body needs for
health overall. Whether it's healthier
blood, healthier digestive system,
healthier brain, healthier heart,
healthier kidneys, I mean, we're it's
all connected. And there's over 600 poor
health conditions that have been linked
to nutritional deficiencies.
>> It's simple. I don't understand why
people make it make it so hard, Dr.
Wallik. Well, that's because they've
been taught the doctor are second only
to God. And when a doctor says, "Don't
waste your money on vitamins and
minerals. Just eat right. You get
everything you need." People say, "Well,
my doctor says I can get everything I
need just from eating right." Well,
those doctors should be put in jail
because you cannot. Uh, plants do not
make minerals. And minerals make up
twothirds of the 90s minerals. Plants do
not make minerals. Plants take carbon
dioxide out of the air and make
vitamins, amino acids, fatty acids.
That's that's true. But those 60
minerals comes from the soil. Now,
here's a scary thing. Nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform blank
around the crust of the earth. They
occur in veins like gold and silver.
There's some places, the land flowing
with milk and honey, where people live a
long healthful life. And there's other
places where they eat the same recipes,
they don't get the same results. Why is
that? Well, because if you're living in
the land flowing with milk and honey,
you're getting all these minerals
because the milk is not cow's milk or
goats milk. It is glacial milk. Okay.
When you look at the Hunzas, their
average life expectancy is 120 because
they have all the glaciers grinding up
the rocks up in the mountains, the
Himalayan mountains. They drink that
glacial milk water. They use it in
cooking. They use it to fertilize their
gardens and fields and irrigate their
gardens and fields. They live to be 120.
They don't have a single medical doctor.
We have medical doctors in the world.
Just ask them. And yet we our life
expectancy is only 75.
glacial milk for irrigating the crops.
That's how you get the nutrition in the
food, folks.
And when you're not doing that, when the
water that is being used to to water
doesn't does not have the minerals,
you're getting
empty food.
>> Okay. Well, what what what happened?
What happened in n in uh 1882 that
changed everything? We went to
electricity for thousands and thousands
of years, 3,000 years or more. We were
getting our minerals supplements from
the wood ashes and coal ashes we're
putting into our food. We're putting
into the gardens in the fields as
fertilizer. And wood ashes and coal
ashes are 95% minerals and two or 3%
carbon.
Well, at 3:00 in the afternoon, Monday,
September 4th, 1882,
um Thomas Edison pulled the switch on
the first commercial electric jing
plant. And that was the beginning of the
end for our health because by 1900
suddenly now we had over 50 new diseases
nobody have seen before and doctors said
oh these are science of genetics had
just been discovered. Okay so oh it's a
genetic thing and that's why all these
people are coming down with these
diseases and um it's not true. There are
no jiggling transmitted disease. Well we
have five people in my family the same
disease. Well they're all eating the
same recipe or live in the same county
or whatever and there's something or
doing the same. It is not a genetic
disease. Even if you have five people in
your family with the same disease
>> and and I did I mean I I had my mother,
my aunts, you know, all having some of
these same conditions which then is how
the doctors were able to justify I have
it because of genetics. Well, if it's
genetic, then I wouldn't have been able
to reverse anything. Not saying that our
products treat your urus anything, but
folks,
I posted on my YouTube on my Facebook
page, Dr. W, like before and after
pictures that have been going on back
for the last 10 years, just 10 years,
and the changes. And I've had people
reach out and say,
"There's no way possible you can be
aging backwards." Well, I am.
I am. And I love it. Absolutely love it.
So for all those X's.
Oh yeah. Um Dr. Wick, let's go to some
hands. We have some hands here with us.
And folks, if you are live with us and
you would like to ask Dr. Wallik a
question, go ahead and raise your
virtual hand. Go to the reactions
uh button in the Zoom menu and you'll
find that raise hand option. If you are
out on YouTube, Rum, Facebook, Rumble,
Truth, Social, um, all of the different
locations that we are now streaming, and
you would like to join us live, go ahead
and pop on over to Daily with
Doczoom.com
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12:50
p.m. Pacific time. So, Dr. Wallick,
let's go up and Miriam, go ahead and
unmute yourself. Hello, my friend.
Welcome to Daily with Doc. Hey, Becca.
Hey, Dr. Wall. Thank you for taking my
call. I have two questions if there's
time for both of them for two different
questions.
>> Okay. The first one is, I have a um I
know someone who gets migraines. I used
to get migraines and I no longer get
migraines, but I've taken so many
products. Could you tell me exactly what
to recommend to her to um help her head
feel better?
>> Okay. Well, there's many things could be
going on there. Okay, [clears throat]
she needs to be getting rid of all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
bar on oats, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks, no buckwheat, no carbonated diet
drinks, no carbonated water. And then
per 100 pounds of body weight. Do you
have any idea how much she weighs?
>> About my size, 100 pounds.
>> Okay. 100 pounds, that's one healthy
brain and heart pack per month. A half
of dose twice a day, one bottle a month
of the MSM. So, you take three twice a
day. Okay, she can take three of those
twice a day. That'll be two bottles a
month of Septive. She also needs the
I26. We have the tubils, we have the
pills, we have the powder. I already
have three doses of I26 a day and that's
going to help her rebuild the white
matter in the brain and spinal cord.
Okay. So, you know, does she just have
things going on there? Uh because she
has low blood sugar, all that kind of
stuff. Well, she does she have diabetes
or high blood pressure?
I don't know. I don't know. I was going
to recommend these things to her, but I
can call with her sometime if that's
>> Okay. Well, go ahead. No, go ahead and
just give her that recipe and let's
start there. Let's see how we do.
>> Okay, great.
>> Second one quickly.
>> Um, I have been on the 90 for life for
maybe 10 years and my health has
improved so much, but I was not paying
attention to my eyes and I was just
diagnosed with glaucoma. So, can you
tell me what I should add to my program?
>> Okay. table glow in the eye, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. So, you get rid of all the bad
foods you get on how much you weigh? You
said 100 pounds thing. Okay. So, one
hell of the brain and heart pack a
month. A half a dose twice a day. One
bottle a month in the MSM. Go ahead and
take um three of those twice a day.
Synaptive, take three of those twice a
day. That's two bottles a month. The
I26, you want three servings a day. I
like the chewables myself, but the pills
and capsules, we sell a lot of those.
Okay. But also the occutive.
I want you to take three of those twice
a day. They're small bottles. Okay? So
you need two of those bottles a month.
And you get a mouse approach to the
skull squeezing the optic nerve, the
optic artery, the optic vein causing the
the um uh pleasure to go up in the eye.
Okay. And um there you go. So give it a
shot and then give us a call because
you're going to have a great story.
>> Great. Thank you. Good. Yeah. Don't
don't don't let them talk you into
surgery.
>> Okay. No way.
>> Okay. Bye. Bye.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Miriam.
Great questions. And yes, I'm so glad.
So, I've been following Miriam for a
little bit and she's just vibrant. I
love it. Dr. Wellik, let's go to the
next question and I'm going to call on
Deved. So, Devid,
go ahead and let me see if we can get
you unmuted. My friend, he's had his
hand his other hand up and contacted me
before. Um, so Devid, go ahead and
unmute, please.
>> Yeah, I've unmuted. I'm not sure about
the background sound. Can you hear me?
You hear me? Okay. Okay, great. Hey,
doc. Hey, Doc. Um, I I'll be I'll be
talking with you next week about the uh
the egg and the cholesterol thing like
we talked about on Fred's that time, but
contacting here on Rebecca today uh
because um I'm about to be taking my dog
into today shot and um and I'm and the
thing is that last week
>> Oh. Uh
>> oh. Yeah, he's got some. So to finish
his question, Dr. Dr. Wik, he's getting
ready to take his pup in for a rabies
shot and he's wanting to know your view
on that as a veterinarian.
>> Okay. Well, rabies shots one of the
safest shots out there when when it
comes to dogs. Okay. Um, and rabies of
course back in the days of the Bible was
a terrible, terrible disease. You get a
wolf or a coyote or a dog, get rabies
and go through the community and bite
people and give people rabies and stuff
like that. It was a terrible thing. So
they came out with the vaccination was
very very good and um it's one of those
things where it doesn't cause any
problems for the pets, doesn't cause any
problems for the people who own the
pets. It's a very safe vaccination, a
lot of experience with it.
And so if you don't get the rabies shot
and they have a a law uh in your
community that you must if you have a
dog, you must have you know raot because
they don't want to have anything
happening in the community. So they they
pass a law that says all dogs must be
vaccinated for rabies. Then you're
risking, you know, tickets, you know,
high-end money thing. So, uh, and rabies
shots do not kill dogs. Rabies shots do
not kill the owners. It's a very, very
safe vaccine.
>> So, how do they contract rabies?
>> Um, by a bite from a rabid carnivore, a
dog, a coyote, a wolf. Okay. and through
saliva. It's the saliva that carries the
virus, the rabies virus.
>> All right, thank you so much for that
answer, Dr. Wallik. Next, let's go on
over to Phyllis with her hand up. I
think she's the next one. Phyllis, go
ahead. And you are on live with Dr.
Wallik.
>> Hey, Dr. Wallik.
>> Hey.
>> You have a contingent of loyal viewers
out in YouTube land and they have all
kinds of great questions. I have several
of them. First of all, Joe has a client.
He is an 81year-old man, 5'8,
159 pounds.
Joe says that his client has good bone,
but the client is wondering if he might
have a possible issue with bone marrow.
Is that possible even if his density is
good?
>> Yes. Okay, it's possible. Um because the
bone marrow can fill up with connective
tissue and the actual bone bony bone to
be normal. And when you lose your bone
marrow, okay, um it gets filled up with
connective tissue and scar tissue. You
lose your immune system because your
bone marrow is where your white blood
cells, your antibodies and platelets and
red blood cells are formed. So, um, if
he's worried about that, he needs to be
taking our, um,
let's see here, bone builder. He can
take five of those twice a day. I do
that. I take five twice a day. The bone
builder. Um, I also take, uh, the let's
see here. I like our vitamin D3. Even
though I live in Southern California, I
get out and I do sunning two or three
days a week and spend half hour out in
the sun just purposely to get the
sunlight, but I still take my day.
Also wouldn't hurt to make sure that
getting the rebound or sports drink as
opposed to soft drinks and that kind of
stuff and juices or sports drink.
Rebound has 100 nutrients in it
including 75 minerals which help the
bones. Okay.
So that's where I would go.
Joe was also wondering um about
gallbladder stones and kidney stones and
are they both caused by osteoporosis or
do they have different causes? Again,
this would be gallbladder stones and
kidney stones.
>> Okay, they're two different issues.
Okay, kidney stones have to do um with
calcium metabolism and you know you're
losing calcium out of your bones because
you're not getting enough calcium in
your diet. Okay, where does the calcium
go? It comes out of your bones. But then
you get some of it go to your kidneys.
You get kidney stones that are calcium.
The gallbladder stones, gallstones have
to do with liver health. And so this is
where you need the healthy brain and
heart pack. You need the MSM. Um, you
need our ultimate enzymes. We call the
ultimate enzymes a gallbladder bottle
because we put bile in there and the
bile will actually help melt the um
gallstones, but you need the 90
essential nutrients to make the liver
happy so it won't make any more
gallstones. Okay.
>> Would the ultimate enzymes be helpful in
in getting rid of those gallbladder?
>> As I say, the ultimate enzymes, we call
it the gallbladder in a bottle. Okay.
Because we do put the uh bile from the
slaughterhouse cattle. We put it in
there. I think we're the only company on
earth that puts bile into our enzymes.
Okay. We call it the gallbladder
bottles. Our ultimate enzymes. I take
three of those with each meal. I only
weigh 142 pounds and I'm 84. Most people
think I'm in my 50s.
>> Man, oh man. I am gonna love those
enzymes. And finally, Aaliyah is
wondering,
you talk about no oils with the bad
foods. We're not supposed to consume
oils. What about oils from soaps, etc.
that we put on our skin and our hair?
And she gives the example of shea
butter, cocoa butter. Are those oils
okay to touch to our skin and hair?
>> Well, if you make them, if you make it
yourself and you use it immediately,
fine. If you buy it from the store, you
don't know that it hasn't been sitting
in a barn somewhere or warehouse at 120
degrees for three summers before they
shipped it to your your sales place.
Okay? And that heat turns those oils
when they're good, when they're
immediately squished out of the food,
okay? But after a couple of days at the
heat, it turns into trans fats
heterosytoines. They cause cancer.
And so you don't you don't want see you
don't want those things in a bottle
because you don't know it doesn't say
>> these were made in in 2022
and we just got them now in August of
2023.
Okay. And so they've been in a warehouse
in the heat
>> in Southern California for for a year.
No,
>> I I had no idea. We need to check on the
origin of those substances that we put
on our skin and hair because they absorb
quickly.
Back to you, Becca.
>> All right. Thank you so much, fellas.
And let's go right over to our next hand
that is up, Dr. Wallik.
And we have Zack. Zack, go ahead and
How come I can't find unmute you?
if you could unmute. There you go.
>> Becca, you have a lot of fans.
Congratulations on that. Wow. We're
excited and thank you for having Dr.
Wallik here all the time. We uh we have
a group of more than 25 that meet five
days a week and we talk nothing about
Dr. Wallak. And we we mention you,
Becca. The great job you're doing. Thank
you and the team.
>> Yes, sir. Um, uh, crib death. Crib
death, the rel, you've talked about that
in the past and the relationship with
selenium and the contribution you did to
have that added in baby formula. Could
you just share a little bit about that?
There's a client who is very grateful.
You've helped her with a lot of issues
and she just wants a little explanation
of what you've done in that area.
>> Okay. Well, um, we got to go way back to
you. You heard the story today so far
about the 500 sheep that died. Okay. And
um, [clears throat]
uh, we got that big grant for $21
million for for 10 years. After that
grant was over, I went to the Yorks
Primate Center in 1976. And I wasn't
there for just a couple of months. I
found the first non-human case of Sizzy
Rose. It's a picture that's on the front
of the book, Epigenics with me with that
baby monkey. Okay. It's a space monkey.
Okay. And um it had certain it had um
the um disease. Okay. Um
it's caused cycrosis.
And I sent the slides out to five
different pathologists, five different
medical schools. I I didn't tell them
it's from a monkey. I just said, "I
think this is cyrosis. What do you
think?" And on their letterheads, they
all came back said, "Yeah, these are
obvious cases of cyic roses." And I told
them, "From a monkey, we may have a
starting a colony of laboratory animals
to study the disease." They're all
excited. And then I got permission to do
the the biopsies in the other 23 baby
monkeys or 24 baby monkeys, a colony,
and they all had cyrosis. So, I knew it
was something the dietitians were doing,
playing around with the the food and the
diets and everything because
[clears throat] they weren't related
other than that they were monkeys. They
didn't have the same mother or father.
And um they summarily fired me. Okay.
When I gave my presentation that I was
going to give to the federal government
and they fired me and that's when I went
back to school. I was teaching
nutrition. I said I might as well get
this degree become a naturopathic
doctor. Okay. And my attorney Jonathan
Eward and I, you know, we're dealing
with this and cyrosis and musculus and
we worked with Jerry Lewis and we worked
with him. Jerry Lewis, we found the
convention and cure for
Musvi
in 200 let's see here um uh we took it
2011 uh we took it to the
September
um 4th we took it to the uh annual
meeting of the cysosis foundation I I
take it back to Musi association they
summarily fired Jerry Lewis put a gag
order on him so he couldn't say anything
about that we had found the cost of
energy.
The next day on the 5th of September
2011 they shut down his teleathon even
though he had raised $2.6 billion
dollars for them over 46 years. What a
terrible story. Well, so Jonathan and I,
we used all this information and data uh
in eight um trials against the FDA in
federal court. we won and they had they
forced all these baby farmers in similac
to put these nutrients in there. Okay.
Uh and suddenly now all these baby
diseases went away including son of
death syndrome and doctors were saying
death syndrome was caused by the mothers
laying on the babies and suffocating
them. Okay. It was just simple
nutritional deficiency. The babies were
dying of heart attacks. Okay. Uh I did a
big uh uh interview a couple of months
ago with Charlie Ward, you know, big big
guy from from um Europe and his zoom
goes all over the world and um told the
story about that and of course the citiz
went away and a surprise to me son of
death syndrome went away. Okay. And um
because it was just a simple deficiency
of the nutrients in the baby formulas
when we put when we forced them to put
it in the baby formulas son of death
syndrome went away
and um it was just a simple nutritional
deficiency. We have been trying to get
these nutrition nutrients put into the
baby formulas for years and the medical
doctors wouldn't let all those minerals
are toxic. You can't put them in baby
formulas. And so when we finally got
them in there we ended cyicosis muscular
and simil syndrome. So just a very
simple nutritional deficiency, okay?
Causing um the heart attack uh caused by
this deficiency. And this heart attack
is see you're seeing this now. Um
there's um
kids in their two, three, four, five
years old dying of these heart attacks.
They're not on baby formulas anymore.
Okay? And then we're getting kids in
their teens dying of um these heart
attacks. They're on a baby formulas
anymore. And when they get to be in
their teens, they're going out with
their buddies. They're eating badly and
eating fried foods and drinking all
these soft drinks and not taking
vitamins, metals. If they do get
vitamins, medals, they give it to the
dog under the table. They don't take
them and that kind of stuff. Okay? And
so that's why you're seeing all these
young athletes, including um uh let's
see here, LeBron James, Ronnie James, 18
years old, great great kid. Uh very very
very good. He'll be a professional
basketball player and he had a near
fatal heart attack. Okay, why would that
happen? He's, you know, only 18 years
old. He's fit. He's, you know, doing all
this, but he wasn't getting all the
nutrition. Was he eating gluten? I don't
know the answer to that. Was he taking
all the right supplements? I don't know
the answer to that. But he had this
heart attack. And thank God he survived.
Okay. and we passed on information to
LeBron James to pass to his son to get
him on all the uh nutrients, proper
nutrients to stay away from the bad
stuff so he won't have another issue
like this because the second time it's
usually worse than the first time. Okay?
And so um this is something that people
have to understand. Plants do not make
minerals and minerals make up twothirds
of our 90th centur 60 of the 90 cents of
nutrients are minerals. Plants do not
make minerals. If there's no minerals in
the soil or they only have the three the
plants are happy with, you could be 57
sharp. That's why you have 18 different
diseases. The doctor says, "Oh, you got
bad genes because you have all these all
these genetic diseases." No, you know,
you're just not supplementing and you're
you're you're eating the same food that
your twin brother's eating, but he lives
two counties away and and he is
supplementing. And so that's why he's
not getting he's not on all the
prescription drugs that you're on, okay?
Because you're not getting the
nutrition. And so these are the sort of
things that we're in control of. We get
get rid of all the bad foods, get them
all the 90 cents nutrients and um
you know if they're exercising they need
to take the rebound or sports drink
shrink which we made for Theo Ratliff.
Uh he was a mess. The Ratliff he lost
his he had a $25 million contract. No,
excuse me, $35 million contract. And he
lost that because he had bone to bone
arthritis knees. 24 years old and uh
basketball player. Um let's see here.
Mike Glenn, okay, the Stinger, a
basketball player, we had helped with
his issues. He brought um Theo Ratliff
to us. We we came up with the healthy
bone and joint pack for him, which is a
healthy start pack and our glucelone and
joint pack. We came up with a rebound or
sports drink for him. And he played for
another 11 years and made a hundred
million dollars.
Now, he also did a beautiful thing with
some of his money. talking about his
money the Ratliff. Okay. Okay. He he
came up with a community an activity
center. Okay. The Ratliff did activity
center. The Ratliff community center
and he has this for young people
and he gives them free services.
What a great thing to do for your
community.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Dr. Wallik
and Zach.
This there is no paid advertising here,
but I do want to thank you so much,
Zach, for for your kind words. We
appreciate you and your whole entire
group. And that's what this is all
about, folks.
sharing information that allows them to
make a more educated
decision on what they can do for
themselves.
Dr. Wick, I have one more hand that is
up. So, let's go right over to Patty.
Patty, go ahead and unmute yourself,
please.
>> Hi, everyone.
>> Hi, Patty. How can we help you?
>> Hi.
>> Hi. Um, so I have a question. One of our
associates with Youngevity wanted to
know um what she can recommend her
sister-in-law or cousin or something
like that. I don't have all the
information. I know the little boy is
six years old. He is above his weight
that he should be. He has urinary
incontinents.
he was when he was born. I'm not sure if
he when he came out he had the umbilical
cord wrapped around his neck or while he
was in the tummy, but that was one of
the um questions that or problems that
he had was the umbilical cord around his
neck and he's six years old.
>> Okay. So, he he's
urinating a lot, right?
>> He can't hold it. Yes. So, he he has to
wear a diaper at six.
>> Okay. Does he have to change diapers in
the middle of the night or?
>> No, I think it's like he has to wear a
diaper all the time because he can't
hold it.
>> Okay. And you don't know how much he
weighs?
>> No, but he's um above his weight. He's a
little um over.
>> Okay. So, let's say six years old, let's
say what autopsy, it's a quarter inch
thick. If I approaches a skull at
autopsy, it's um an inch and a half to
two inches squeezing all the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves and also the spinal cord.
And there's a chapter in this book for
each of the cranial nerves. Okay. And
the spinal cord there's 37 different
There you go. Thank you. You get there's
37 different diseases you can get. 37
different diseases you can get. Okay.
Having osteoporosis of the skull. And
again, I would consider that for him.
Uh, so it it's six years old. He needs
to be taking the 90 essentials of
nutrients. He likes if he takes pills,
he can take the um one dose of the
healthy brain and heart pack per month,
a half a dose uh a day, okay? Half a
dose a day. And he can cut that in half.
So he take a quarter of a dose twice a
day kind of thing. Okay. And then I also
want him to have a rebound uh you know
in the middle of the day, not at night.
He'll be up all night. Also, he needs
the vitamin D3. He needs the our
um let's see her seasoned salt from
Australia. Uh he also needs to have the
I'd get him on the um uh Synaptive. You
take two of those a day. Start him out
with two a day, one at breakfast, one at
dinner time. He also needs the I26. He
could have one of those chewles at
breakfast, lunch, and dinner. So, three
of those chewles a day. They come in
vanilla ice cream or banana, coconut.
[clears throat] They do come in capsules
um and powder. I also want him to have
um our bone builder. Okay. Our bone
builder. I want him to take
>> two of those twice.
>> I'm sorry.
>> MSM or no? Yeah, MSM is fine, but Okay,
but he still needs all this other stuff.
Don't don't pick one. Don't pick one
nutrient,
okay? He needs a complete program
because he's got something very serious
here.
>> Yes.
>> Or his heart, his liver, his thyroid,
his kidneys. Okay. And you said he did
have kidney issues also.
>> Uh the not that she knows.
>> Okay. Yeah, it could be just the skull
squeezing the spinal cord causing all
this urination stuff.
>> Perfect. Thank you, Dr. Wall.
>> Yeah, keep us informed. Will you keep us
informed
turn around to the good very quickly and
I apologize, but I got to go here.
>> Gotta go, doc. So, thank you again so
much for joining us on Daily with Doc,
folks.
We want to thank you for taking the
time. You're not just taking time,
you're investing time into your own
self. And if you are listening on behalf
of a family member or a friend, you're
also investing this time into helping a
greater cause.
You didn't hear this just by chance.
There is a purpose and we encourage you
to take that
time or take the time that you've spent
here and use it wisely in sharing with
others program with with those that you
know. Doesn't matter what platform
you're on. You can just grab that link,
share it, copy paste in a in a text
message. They make it so easy now. And
we um want to also ask you to save and
subscribe to our different channels.
Now, we have something special going on,
and this is for all of those that do
share the program. We have what's called
DWD
giveaway. Is that what it is to Yes.
dwdgaway.com.
we are doing a promotion to help build
awareness and through this promotion I
will be giving away prizes. Um so
there's a total of 11 people that will
be winning uh something from me over the
month of August and I think we will
depending on how well it goes we'll
continue that as well. So go to
dwdgiveaways.com
and AJ is getting that all register for
our giveaway and then you get points
every time that you share with the
different platforms. So folks, we invite
you to help us get this message out so
that we can, you know, reach around the
world because this is not like what I
said in the beginning. It's not
demographic. This is a worldwide
epidemic when it comes to nutritional
deficiencies and the conditions that
have been linked to them. I'm sure that
you know somebody who has something that
might have been mentioned on this
program or is affected by or their
family is affected by one of the poor
health conditions.
When something has been determined to be
nutritional deficiency,
it only makes sense. You you work on
giving the body what it needs with that
extra support. There's only one way that
the body can go and that's that's up
for the better. So there are times where
yes,
it is um you know getting back to almost
not get there folks. Let's be more
proactive rather than reactive and share
this message and take action on it for
ourselves and our families. If I could
get my co-hosts up with me, that would
be absolutely fantastic. I could not do
this without them. As we have Mr.
Giraffe there behind Albert joining us
here from South Africa making sure that
everybody is getting into the room
smoothly. We also have Phyllis who comes
to us from uh many many years being with
Dr. Wallik and sharing this program over
the airwaves which I do want to do a
quick shout out. KCO KOMY listeners,
thank you for listening. Thank you for
continuing to allow us to be able to
serve you with this information. So,
thank you to MZ and Dave Michaels for
making this program available still on
the radio and the other radio locations.
Let us know where you are listening
from. Go to one of our uh channel on one
of our shows and let us know where you
are listening to or watching from. And I
also want to thank Sherry uh for all
she's doing. she's helping out more in
not only letting people in but also
fielding in those those questions that
are coming in here on Zoom and answering
those as well. And then we have
Marilyn who is doing the dictation of
what Dr. Wallik is recommending. And
that's one of the biggest positive
advantages to being here live with us
Monday through Friday from 12 to 12:50
p.m. Pacific time is you are able to
open up that chat and see the questions
and the responses that are being
presented on the program. You can do a
screenshot of that and then take it to
your health coach and say, "Hey, Dr. Dr.
Wallik recommended this for me or I know
somebody that has this condition. How do
I get the products that Dr. Wallik
recommended? And and then we have AJ
helping me with all of the technical
stuff and making sure that the stream is
going out and about. And we also have
somebody that's not up on the screen.
There he is. We have Coach Rod who's
also helping making sure people get in
and watching out on the different
channels for questions to help fill
those questions as well. Folks, it takes
a team. It takes an army to be able to
present this information in the way that
we do. And I just cannot say enough how
much I appreciate these people. They are
just a small handful of those that I
have on my team that are able to join us
during this time slot. If you are not
working with a coach and you would like
to, you've never spoken to anybody about
longevity or Dr. Wallik before, then go
to our website w uh dailywithdoc.com
at your questions and also request to
have a 15minute free consultation with
one of my coaches. Again, this is for
people that have never ordered and are
not already talking to somebody about
longevity. Get back with that person
that you started talking with. They may
also be one of these amazing certified
holistic health coaches. And we want to
make sure that they since they took that
time to share this information that they
also have the opportunity to continue to
help you on this health journey. Now, I
don't think that I forgot anything.
Maybe not. But again, go to our
channels, like, share, comment, and
dwdgeways.com.
dwdgiveaways.com.
Wait, what did I forget, AJ? Oh, did you
put it in the chat?
That's way down there.
>> Yeah, there's no S on giveaway.
Oh, DWD very important dwdgiveaway.com.
So, until next time.
Bye for now everyone.
Heat. Heat.
Hey, hey, hey.